[Applaudissements]
la création d'un fond dédié aux dégâts
irréversible causés par les effets des
changements climatiques pour les pays
les plus vulnérables
[Applaudissements]
depuis plus de 30 ans discutable chemin
de vos fans la création d'un fond n'est
pas une question de charité il s'agit
clairement d'un acompte sur
l'investissement à plus long terme dans
notre avenir commun et un investissement
dans la justice climatique lance la
ministre des changements climatiques du
Pakistan
il y a des parties qui sont responsables
d'une situation et d'autres qui doivent
être soutenus pour continuer à survivre
pour moi ça va comme je dis toujours
l'humanité a gagné sur la question du
financement
prog
rès la réduction des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre essentielles pour
contenir le réchauffement climatique à
1,5 degrés
nous sommes issus de ne pas y être
parvenus déclare Franz stemermans de
l'Union européenne car l'Union
européenne comme de nombreux pays ont
fortement insisté pour que le texte
final inclut une mention quant aux
retrait graduelle de toutes les énergies
fossiles or le blocage de nombreuses
étapes pétroliers a visiblement
fonctionné et puis donc Spider si nous
n'accélérons pas la réduction de nos
émissions aucune somme d'argent sur la
planète ne pourra compenser pour les
pertes et les dommages que nous subirons
dit-il tout n'aura pas été perdu à la
cop27 avec la création de ce fond mais
plusieurs grandes questions restent sans
réponse qui contribuera au fond et qui
pourra en recevoir quant à la question
des énergies fossiles plusieurs se
demandent si elle sera à l'ordre du jour
de la prochaine COP qui se déroulera aux
Émirats arabes unis un état pétrolier
ici Elisa serrer Radio-Canada charmer le
chèque en Égypte